[Applaudissements]
benjamin castaldi vous le voyez doc
gynéco comme celle d'aller yeux très
petit non ça va c'est bon j'ai rendez
vous le 20 je voulais dit le 20 janvier
deux rendez vous le prouver à cause de
vous je m'attendais à un vrai complexe
non non je vais refaire tout genre c'est
tout et pour avoir fait tout ce que vous
n'êtes pas de vous arrêtez pas de
monnaie voulez vous avez pas les grands
noms mais ça ne vous dira pas mais en
échange en région comme ça c'est tout
moi j'adore vous que ce que voit pas ça
va casser niveau dans l'émission bien
entendu voilà n'aurait pas déjà là non
faut dire je ne fais rien voilà tu es
très bon comme tu dis à ta femme
oui le sait bien sur quoi elle a dit
alors tout mais ça va pas durer oui non
je vais tout refaire la décision ce qui
conduira dans cinq ans une aveugle
chaque année ça
[Applaudissements]
la dernière fois je suis venu le
chercher en camionnette et madison
smartt bell et suis allé chez lui il m'a
dit je prends ma main il avait prendra
pas dans un fidèle il n'a plus la la il
ne voit plus rien il a pris les devants
mais n'arrive plus bas des propos à
savoir wii alors donc
donc c'est vrai que c'était très
compliqué de donner notre en tant que
chroniqueur médias parce que c'est vrai
que tu es un homme extraordinaire des
impôts est fabuleux profondeur doivent
incroyable tu es un amour tu étais mon
frère mais si je m'en réfère ou qu'elle
est et qu'on devrait attendre d'un
chroniqueur médias
tu n'as aucune des qualités requises
c'est ok ça fait ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'a pas parlé je je je me rends donc en
conséquence de quoi
en conséquence de quoi
soit je m'étais dit ce soit je m'étais 0
et en fait pas par respect pour tous ses
chroniqueurs disparu trop tôt qui
travaille beaucoup de ses chroniqueurs
donc disparaître auto keane qui
travaille beaucoup mais qui n'avait
aucun talent je te mets 0